[Musique]
c'est une émouvante plongée dans
l'intimité de l'idole des jeunes Johnny
Haliday sans phare se donne à voir dans
une exposition à Paris la mise en scène
chapautée par Laeticia veuve du chanteur
retrace en musique et en objet une
carrière de tous les superlatif 57 ans
de scène 3200 concerts et quelques 11
millions d' album vendu le plus
légendaire des rockurs francophones ne
laisse personne indifférent c'est un
chanteur mythique que l'on a envie de
garder toujours dans son cœur la visite
est thématique son enfance sa
discographie son rapport aux fans mais
aussi la scène lieu mythique des fans de
Johnny cette loge de l'Olympia la salle
où il a le plus souvent chanté dans sa
carrière près de 270 fois on a
reconstitué le plus fidèlement possible
et en collaboration avec les gens de
Olympia euh ça loge et vous voyez ces
coffrets de préparation c'est le parfums
qu'il utilisait son ses cheveux ses
brosses l'exposition fait aussi revivre
la bête de scène que Johnny fut avec ses
lives grandioses à couper le souffle
dans ce lieu immersif son et lumière à
360°r les tubes s'enchaînent Gabriel que
je t'aime ou encore allumer le
[Musique]
feu
c'est assez prenant c'est un vraiment un
bel hommage à Johnny vraiment quand on
est là au milieu c'est ça fait quelque
chose quoi la discographie de Johnny un
patrimoine français à elle seu et pour
toutes les générations même des jeune
comme Maxime 20 ans Johnny ça a toujours
été une icône énorme et j'ai toujours
adoré ces chansons le personnage aussi
qui est tellement iconique voilà johnny
c'est c'est un des plus grands
personnages français johnnyid aussi une
dans ce couloir les bijoux emblématiques
du rockur pavent le chemin vers le plus
iconique d'entre eux sa croix latia nous
a fait le grand honneur de bien vouloir
exposer cette croix que tous les
visiteurs veulent veulent
voir on l'a magnifié
comme comme un très beau bijou ce qu'il
est mais le clou du spectacle est sans
doute le bureau de la villa de Marne la
coquette pièce la plus intime de Johnny
reproduite à l'identique avec les
souvenirs et effets personnels originaux
de toute une vie on s'attend à ceux qui
sortent de la porte pour venir nous
inviter et c'est vraiment très très
émouvant de de voir son salon et on a
toujours l'impression qu'il est toujours
là et toujours parmi nous c'est ici que
Johnny est mort en 2017 pour
l'organisateur de l'exposition recréer
cet espace était une pression immense
après avoir discuter une heure avec
Létitia elle me dit mais allons voir le
bureau la là j'ai senti par 1000 points
de détail des photos des livres et tout
ça j'ai senti une sorte de poids en me
disant il va falloir être à la hauteur
de de ce monument avant de partir les
fans pourront se recueillir une dernière
fois devant un montage retraçant les
funéraill monumental de Johnny au son de
récuyem pour un fou on replonge dans la
journée du 9 décembre 2017 où des
centaines de milliers de Français ont pu
dire adieu au
tolier